bonjour aujourd'hui je vous présente les
routes du miel kate un beau livre sur la
fabrication et la récolte de miel à
travers la planète
donc c'est un livre qui est édité aux
éditions ausoni est donc en plus d'être
un beau livre avec deux fabuleuses
photos sur la récolte et les abeilles se
dit nous apprend aussi énormément de
choses sur comment ils récoltaient ce
fameux lecteur est tout tout au travers
de la planète
donc on apprend énormément de choses sur
comment et récolté à la main en afrique
le miel comment il arrive à dompter
toutes ces abeilles est donc l'auteur
enfin les deux auteurs égrène la planète
complète pour voir un peu comment on
fait que ce soit au milieu de la savane
en afrique ce soit dans les villes que
ce soit à new york ou à paris
vraiment il ya tous les étalages complet
de la récolte du miel dont ce livre
accueille du recensement de tous les
habitudes de leurs méthodes de
fonctionnement mais j'ai surtout retenu
un parmi tant d'autres qui est la
récolte du miel au népal on voit une
personne donc un affûteur à flanc de
falaise aller chercher à la main
suspendu
avec des cordes qu'il a forcément
pressés lui-même voilà c'est vraiment là
cette image moi que je retiens de ce
livre on voit finalement que en plus de
récolter quelque chose de faibles pour
eux il ya aussi tous et cet art
ancestral finalement qu'ils arrivent à
faire perdurer sur la récolte de ce
nectar saison et le nouveau livre de
jacques perrin qui précède un film qui
va sortir en début d'année 2016 dans ce
livre qui est magnifiquement illustré de
photos et du tournage et tes photos
spécifiquement réalisé pour le livre
jacques perrin revient sur toute
l'histoire de la campagne européenne
donc deux moins 20000 à aujourd'hui les
périodes de glaciation de l'installation
de la forêt la domestication des animaux
et tout ses répercussions sur la vie
animale donc on a de très belles photos
de loudes ours de d'espèces disparues
mais également des espèces qui sont
réintégrés en europe voilà à la fois un
côté très historique de l'aménagement
des forêts et des campagnes en europe et
également un côté écologique est le
bienvenu en cette période de
commentaires
je vous présente aznavour ma vie mes
chansons mais film donc est le dernier
livre sorti sur charles aznavour et avec
charles aznavour surtout donc là on va
suivre toute sa vie son oeuvre mais
égrainé surtout de d'entretiens qu'il a
pu avoir avec le journaliste donc on va
découvrir finalement qu'il a eu un
parcours vraiment atypique et très très
prolifique ce soit au niveau
cinématographique comme au niveau de la
chanson et donc voilà on égrène toute sa
vie à travers des interviews qui
viennent entrecouper qui viennent en
fait et ayez un peu les photos c'est
tout un beau livre qui parcourt donc
comme je voulais 10 et sa vie mais voilà
il ya beaucoup d' affiches de films il
ya beaucoup d' affiches de concerts
beaucoup de photographies de personnes
qu'il a pu rencontrer et qui finalement
on fait aussi à lui sa carrière en
passant par edith piaf par jean cocteau
et après toute sa filmographie est quand
même foisonnante et que malgré donc
cette implication dans le cinéma il a eu
aussi et enfin il a continué de chanter
donc voilà c'est de vie en parallèle ses
deux carrières qu'il a réussi à mener en
parallèle
donc voilà il revient sur tout ça sur
cette vie commence à ces mises en place
et comment il a réussi à perdurer des
années 50 jusqu'à aujourd'hui
alors donc c'est un beau livre qui
retrace toute sa vie sa vie s'est formé
en ses chansons son cinéma mais aussi
son application sur la vie politique
arménienne donc voilà il ya tout ce côté
artistique mais aussi cette implication
là qu'il a eu lui avec l'arménie et donc
forcément ses origines donc vraiment
c'est un livre à conseiller
pas uniquement pour les amoureux
d'aznavour mais un peu pour les amoureux
du milieu culturel français des années
50 aux années 80 90 pour voir un peu
comment ça commence à fonctionner et ce
qu'il y avait vraiment de d'intéressant
le foisonnant à l'époque pour cette fin
d'année les éditions casterman nous
propose un très beau coffret il s'agit
de l'intégrale des oeuvres d'anne qui
bilal de dessinateur de bandes dessinées
ce coffret est l'occasion évidemment
d'avoir tous les albums d'haïti bilal
mais également des albums un petit peu
plus difficiles à trouver comme l'album
un siècle d'amour c'est un coffret qui
vaut 120 euros c'est donc un très beau
cadeau de noël mais qui fera plaisir à
tous les passionnés de bande dessinée